former metropolitan police officer Wayne
cousins has been sentenced to 19 months
in prison at the Old Bailey after
admitting three incidents of indecent
exposure committed in the months before
he kidnapped raped and murdered Sarah
everard he has now been sentenced to 19
months in jail this is on top of his 50
this his whole life jail sentence for
the murder of Miss everard we can listen
to a section of what Mrs Justice May
told him in sentencing a short while ago
for the offense against a count two on
indictment number T
2022-0638 the sentence is one of 19
months imprisonment
there will be concurrent sentences of
six months on each of counts two and
three on indictment T
2022-0320 the total sentence is
accordingly one of 19 months
as I have already said
to the existing whole of life sentence
from which the defendant will never be
released
well Mrs Justice May talked about the
fact that his pattern of behavior had
continued and the fact that these cases
of indecent exposure had not led to any
police action and she said the fact that
no police came to find you can only have
served to increase your belief in your
ability uh to dominate women sexually
without being caught and she talked
about the victims and how they have felt
about this how they have felt shocked
about the aggressive exposure and and
how one of them has really felt enormous
remorse that had she realized at the
time what this man was capable of and
perhaps if the police had taken more
action at the time it would have meant
that he would have been arrested at the
time
this is important of course because
Wayne cousins who's serving a whole life
sentence for the murder of Miss everard
was a serving match police officer at
this at the time
and he carried out
these offenses that he has been found
guilty for today one of them happened
when he was actually meant to be on duty
he was working from home the other one
happened when he used a credit card in
his own name and would have been aware
that his car would have had its number
plate captured as he went to pay for
fast food at a fast food restaurant and
exposed himself to the woman who was
working there we can now talk to our
corresponder Matthew Thompson who is at
the old bayley for us Matthew Thompson
he had pleaded guilty to these three
charges so he would be expecting um a
relatively Hefty sentence but this would
just be added to his whole life jail
sentence won't it
it will yes so it's 19 months in total
for the three offenses of indecent
exposure that breaks down as 19 months
for the first offense which took place
in Woodlands in Kent in November of 2020
and then a subsequent two sentence
sentences of six months each for the
later incidents which were at the fast
food restaurants in Kent in February of
2020 but all of those sentence says are
going to be served concurrently at the
same time which means a total if you
like of 19 months in prison of course in
some ways that is academic because as
the judge made clear Wayne cousins is
already serving a whole life sentence in
prison an hmp Franklin and County Durham
for the kidnap rape and murder of Sarah
everard in 2021 and so he will die in
prison whatever happens but the judge
was I thought very interesting on
exactly why it was important that he be
sentenced for those other crimes even if
it made no practical difference to the
amount of time that he would spend in
prison she said it was first and
foremost important for the
administration of justice for a public
recognition that these crimes took place
but also for some form of restitution
for the victims and as well as she said
to recognize The Bravery of the victims
for coming forward without them without
their actions incoming forward she said
Justice would not be served so for all
those reasons even if it is slightly
academic the judge said it was very
important that he be sentenced for those
crimes in terms of The Facts of what
happened it was interesting to see them
set out at some length in terms of the
first incident which the judge deemed to
be the most serious cousins was in
Woodlands in Kent in November 2020 he
stepped out as a passing lone female
cyclist was passing by
completely naked and began to pleasure
himself in front of her and she then
reported it to police she did actually
pass his car as she was cycling off but
only had a partial remembrance of his
license plate and so for that reason the
police said they were unable to progress
the investigation any further then what
happened in the February of 2021 was Mr
cousins was using a drive-through at a
fast food restaurant in Kent he exposed
himself to two members of female members
of staff at the fast food restaurant
there is CCTV footage of cousin's car
with its license plate in full view also
he used his own credit card to pay for
the food and so the restaurant had a
copy of the receipt with his credit card
number but that first incident on
Valentine's Day on the 14th of February
was not actually reported to police not
at least until two weeks later when he
did the same thing again and again there
was CCTV footage and again he used the
same credit card so there was records of
that the following day it was reported
to police and the fact that it was the
same credit card as a similar incident
that had happened two weeks before but
nothing was done cousins was not
interviewed or contacted by police and
as we know tragically less than a week
later he went on to commit the rape
kidnap and murder of Sarah everard so
this is if you like cousins potentially
unless new allegations emerge of course
cousin's last day in court
but what attention will now turn to is
the extent to which there may have been
options possibilities for stopping him
at some point had police investigated
for example an incident that took place
in Kent in 2015 when his number plate
was taken had they investigated any of
the incidents in November through to
February 2021
could they have stopped cousins could
they have done enough to at least get
him suspended from his role as a police
officer which as we know tragically he
used to then trick Sarah everard into
getting into his car in fact he arrested
her didn't he so there are many options
potentially for investigating uh what
went wrong in the police investigations
themselves that is all of course the
subject of a home Office inquiry under
Dame uh Angelini which is taking place
as we speak so that is where the
attention will turn we know now of
course as we did even prior to today
that Wayne cousins will spend the rest
of his life in prison but now for
important reasons explained by the judge
he's added to that another sentence of
19 months for several counts of indecent
exposure